okay hi everyone welcome to another wolf
language design review this time we are
beginning our
uh long sequence for version 14.0 I
think this is a very our very first 14.0
uh live stream design review
okay
so today it's calculus and algebra
all right let me just get a scope here
okay all kinds of stuff
all right
that I remember that being talked about
years ago
equations with large numbers of roots
like a million
right and so n solve as as we integrated
this method in we took the opportunity
to overhaul and solve and so enso now
has a new Option Max Roots I mean you're
unlikely to have wanted a million roots
um how does it pick which ones you get
if you're only getting three
there's no criteria
okay
so it's like Max items for for such you
know results or something like that it's
just we'll give you we'll give you that
number right or up to that number
and there's no reason to have a more
General name than Roots here that we
could reuse for other functions
like eigenvalues for example
uh
like max cases or some other well for
eigenvalues we did something else we we
have an argument
you know and there are some criteria as
well I remember multivariables
sorry well like that that's just yeah
rank right list of eigenvalues and
biggest to smallest right right
but I'm assuming in this case we just
don't know which route exactly
we're just peeling off roots exactly
um
are there any other functions that you
think might might have the same
treatment in other words yeah so the
idea is for 14 1 we flow the same
updates into solve
okay
for symbolic things you can use similar
methods
um actually yes so and we do some of it
but but we haven't really been using it
for sold yet
so if you can guess a root so so
actually we're already using something
like that starting
15 years ago or something for
transcendental Roots we can count the
number of roots then we can use any
method to find them
which we do
um so so then when you found exactly the
number that you know that is in there
you know you found all of them
and we use numerical methods but
symbolic methods to validate it is an
actual route
that gives you the transcendental root
so we can do what we haven't done
except in a few cases is to take that to
the multivariate case which we plan to
do
so we have count Roots right that's a
univariate root counter yeah
is there a multivariate root counter
that is conceivable
um
yes
um we we don't use them because they're
so incredibly expensive
um there might be some you know so what
we do is upper bounds
so there's like for polynomial system
there's a really poor bound called The
Bernstein bound but there's a much
better bound which is called the mixed
volume bound
uh which we use for both mono drummy and
homotopia remind me how these methods
like monitor me I think I once knew but
can you give me the few sentence summary
how it works so Adam can give you an
intro to to monitor me or or Devendra I
couldn't homotopia I can give you super
detailed so basically basically you you
vary the constances so you have
something equal to zero then you
find some little Loop that goes from
zero to zero and solve the equation
along the loop
and you hope to to end up in a different
solution
by Loop you mean with respect to the
parameters
to yeah you introduce a new parameter so
you you have f equals zero you change it
into f equals a where a goes along a
loop from zero to zero in a complex
plane
and you have more equations then you
have more parameters like this
and and you hope that somehow in that
Loop you will hit
another place where
where f of x really is equal to zero is
that right
or you you will always get into the
place where so at each step of the loop
you you get f of x equals to A since the
the loop ends with zero but
you will get I understand so so you hope
you hope it will be a different route
you you don't have a guarantee that it
will have be a difference right but we
you might kind of like like you were in
one minimum of a function and you took a
a tour of the mountain and you hope that
you know the only thing that you're
defined about the tour of the mountain
is it eventually ends up back in the you
know at sea level or something and you
hope it's going to end up at a different
sea level yeah place then you start
that's kind of interesting
okay
no homotopia
works by so you have an estimate this
better estimate over how many total
routes there are
um basically it's it's counting the
number of integer lattice point in a big
high dimensional polyhedra
so then you start with an equation
system where you know the solution which
has that number of roots
okay um okay it's like
roots of unity type things you know
and then you you introduce a parameter
that takes it from that system with
known Solutions
to the system that you actually want to
solve
okay and then you vary that parameter
until you know typically from zero to
one
and so when it's one you have the system
that you actually want to solve and it's
here you have the system for which you
know the solutions
and the way you vary that you know
typically we set up a differential
algebraic equations just slide to those
other Solutions
as you go there okay okay
and and why
okay why is that called homotopic
because it because it is a homotopia you
vary that parameter I see I got it I got
it I got it you're moving on those parts
and this monodomy is you're kind of
circling around uh yes a um
okay Singularity yeah
that's cool
so
polynomial equations with a million
Roots outside the degree a million or
it's got a whole bunch of or it's a
highly multivariate
yeah right yeah Universe easy to
understand multivarius not so much
if you look at the second example it has
billion roots
which is like an example this one oh the
yeah this one here yeah
so you multiply thousand by thousand by
thousands
yes
and maybe you didn't want those billion
roots
Sandra on live stream is commenting that
it would be nice to have a numerical
function which gives all the roots of
something it's surprisingly hard to get
a list of all routes for complicated
functions
yeah
yeah it is hard I mean so we guarantee
that in the univariate case
but metamorphic I mean first of all
polynomials always both you know
individual and systems but if you take
transcendental which is a whole
different story
we guarantee it for metamorphic
univariate in a box
right
yeah I thought so I mean that was a
that's one of the impressive
achievements right being able to do
those kinds of routes exactly
all right cool okay onward
Planet fields
oh great finite fields for linear
algebra
so
should I look at some of these and and
um is there something to see oh here we
go for example yes
you know this print form
is sort of bugging me
and I'm kind of wondering
you know why don't we at least make this
smaller
I mean it's just like okay I can make
that smaller uh you know on the whole
you know
go ahead yeah but by the time we were
done you know and we played with it I
thought that maybe right you know it's
this balance of you want it to be
readable versus not too big
um but I'll I'll take it down a couple
of uh yeah I think I think we should
talk to design and maybe there's a way
of maybe even we fill in a bit more and
darken that f a bit I think we can take
it to two-thirds of its similar
dimensions
okay
um
what is this 23 to the four there I
think that's society so it's a power
racism size of the field
in the Box
out of the box right I was just thinking
that too it's like why do I want that
repeated all the time
yeah I don't understand I mean it's
never going to be a different thing
particularly not for a matrix
and I am wondering for the print form
for the Matrix why on Earth we don't
just put it outside the whole Matrix
exactly
well it's a list of right it's a list of
lists of right we don't have print forms
okay okay we'll okay but but for the
future then but but but
here
I don't understand why the size of the
finite field is visible outside of the I
mean why isn't that in the F box so to
speak well because the F box is sort of
an action button and that's you know a
thing that you can copy out right
wait a minute just ate it here
this problem just isn't right
the fact that this is not in the box and
then the Box eats it when the Box opens
just it's in the Box expand it I know I
know it's in the box but I'm saying it
isn't visibly in the Box here
I think it is I think you're I think
it's just fainter and and therefore less
uh I see okay I think this needs more
work and I think that you could you know
given all these Clues you could pretty
much just say 23 to the four in this box
and you know with all the angle
bracketing and all this kind of thing
that's going to tell you it's sort of a
finite field and when you click the box
then you see more detail
I just don't think the f is doing much
for us
I I I I I I disagree with that I mean I
think you know
angle brackets on its own right I mean
that can mean any of it it's obscure no
I agree yeah
well look
I just think this needs a bit more work
trying to get the thing all in the Box
minimize the F it just needs to build
you know a little F you know a cluster
of pixels that is reminiscent of an app
basically
okay particularly when it's repeated
like this
okay
but now here we've got the finite field
and these are elements of the finite
field and if I evaluate this which I
hopefully can do here okay now I just
take this Matrix
twice
it's it that's what you did there is
element wise right so okay well let me
just do do this finite field okay
so
okay so that's doing the right thing but
it already would do the right thing like
that is that correct but now if I say
something like determinant of that
that's more interesting or indeed if I
say inverse of that
that's nice so if I say that dot
percent six
cool
and and if I say normal of that
hmm
how do I get the actual identity Matrix
out of this how do I forget the finite
field array
I don't think that's a sensible question
right this is the identity Matrix in the
field right the fields are not
necessarily
you know I still think there are cases
where people are going to want to get
those numbers out just because you're
manipulating it in some other way you're
feeding it into some shift register
calculation or something I just want the
freaking numbers out
so one one thing is replacement rules to
find a few element goes to
to its index not a chance
if we say finite field index
what is it called how do I get it it's a
sub value
of index yeah it's not going to work for
this case so we need a different way to
do it right that's right right and I
mean just remember hash
you know that's a hack okay but just
just remember Stephen I mean these
indices are arbitrary and you know
depending on which representation you
choose right you're gonna deal with I'm
well aware but we know mod 23 it's not
that arbitrary
it can be yeah yes but it isn't
uh I mean are we have two different
there will be two different
representations for mod 23. all right
look I'm telling you people are going to
be is going to I can even think of
algorithms that I have written myself
where I would want this conversion it
comes in you know it comes in as a
standard Matrix because I got it from
who knows what you know off a offer you
know I got it out of a packet that I you
know dissected and I'm going to use some
kind of error correcting code on the
packet I want to take this list of
numbers and I want to turn them all into
Mod 20 you know over gf23 do we want a
special function fin Outfield index that
would just be listable
possibly so but I think we want both
ways in other words I've got a matrix or
a list of numbers I want to make them
all finite field now can I do that if I
say if I say this
and I say that thing of
you know range of 10.
that's that's a different thing actually
so these are coefficients
okay
yeah
for what reason
uh because there is a
representation of Finance field elements
as a list of coefficients of a
polynomial and that's what that's what
it did
okay
all right so I'm telling you guys we
need a way and I would have expected
normal would have done it but maybe it
isn't the right thing
um to go to a plain list of integers
from plain list of integers two so for
yeah so for when if you're not in a if
you're just in a prime field that would
make sense right but from a private
power field
a little bit squiggly it's a little
squiggly it's a bit to say the least
right there is nothing normal about it
fine yeah so it's like from finite field
to finance Fields or something something
like that but I mean look realistically
if I'm in a Prime power field okay
then there are still numbers that I can
see here and I have been in this
situation way too many times with our
system that I can see a number I want
that number this is my objection to the
root objects thing which I hope we're
fixing in this version right I can see
it I just want it how do I get it
you see what I'm saying
did you understand what I'm saying I see
those numbers I want those numbers I
don't know why I want those numbers but
I want those numbers and certainly for
the the uh you know pure Z mod P type
stuff
there's a good reason to want those
numbers it's squigglia in the case of
Prime power Fields yeah that's actually
for the encryption application I just
did I did need to to get the
the thing for get the numbers for
something that was Prime power field all
right so it is useful yeah okay so it
should be I mean maybe
I think that what we've tried to do is
utility functions for the things that
create good flow in programming
as opposed to sub values yes I agree I
mean because we can't use sub values
here you know because it's in The Matrix
I mean you can but it's sort of it's
awkward no no I mean we want to single
hit it with one thing yeah yeah that's
right I agree with you I'm agreeing with
you you can but I'm saying it's it's
yeah it's not the right thing right yeah
um
so
the sub-value thing is the quotes Index
sub-value right
yes so if I take this puppy and I say
sub index
I'll get that okay
so
you know one possibility
is to say
finite field index
another one is from finite field index
or something
well
it's a bit yucky because you would
expect the thing to be listable but it's
not the finite field you know this thing
here
well what do we think about this finite
field index of the thing I think it's a
is it that's what it is a good name
minor field index is great yes I agree
because it also admits it doesn't claim
it's gone it's an index is something
much more arbitrary yeah
mm-hmm
and it's what it is yeah what about from
finite field index
to create them or what yes so it would
have to have the second argument being
the final field exactly yes
why not
seems okay people are going to expect
this to work
I think it's but I think it's the right
decision that it doesn't yeah if you I
mean I think that this is part of what
we discover by using it it's like that
should be there to make a a more flowy
workflow so to speak
yeah
okay let me see what happens here so if
I make a um so in this case for example
if I take this
start to understand things and I say dot
x squared X1
magnificorial
and if I say solve
that equals equals zero equals the next
part yes
should look
yeah what the hell is that uh is does it
have the
do you have the Prototype version or
I hope so the wrong version
it's pretty old
oh it's actually 1331 so yeah well what
the heck
what the heck this says 14.0
what's going on here yeah what type
version
yeah okay somebody completely goofed
do you think that version is is is the
recent version or a prototype
I don't appreciate that that that's
that's the thing
that says 40 no how could it say 40 no
and be a 13 3
and how could it even be a Linux version
something oh is your is your default
evaluator set to something
oh
check that check what your default
evaluator is yeah okay bye
oh threadripper
that looks better
okay dude it's two dollar versions again
just to make sure
it's quite possible it doesn't have
Solutions
well that is is zero okay uh
okay not every quadratic will will have
roots in this field yes so the next what
happens if I say here if I say this is a
number like three
so is that three now Auto converted to
that field yes
what happens if it's a Prime power field
uh it will also be converted so it will
be treated as as the integer
so modular
so every Prime power field contains
Prime field
so it will still be an element of prime
field
I see but but so in the case of finite
field index
or from finite field index the reverse
isn't true there is the prime the prime
field is still sitting inside but there
will be additional Elements which are in
the Prime power field that are not in
the prime field and whose indices might
be more arbitrary yes so you have made
it so that the indices for the in the
Prime power field the indices from one
to p
or 0 to P minus one are the ones for the
prime field is that correct yes yes
okay so and if I were to use here
34 or something
that will be reduced
mod
23 yeah 23 even if this was a it was
Prime Prime power field so it still
wouldn't be an index it would be the the
integer 34 embedders in the field
okay so it's like one in the field other
34 times
yep makes sense
all right so now if I take this
and I were to do for example a root sum
I assume that that's supported here no
that's actually not
okay so it's probably won't do anything
accessible hole has been poked okay what
else needs to be supported I mean
clearly that should be supported right
right
uh what about
um maybe this what about the L functions
things like that other things that use
don't they
don't they do things over over finite
fields that is their coefficients and
things
uh Prime fields
so
but maybe we should go back and look at
them anyway
good I'm gonna have to think about that
but definitely playing fields okay
um
so
and I assume that there are other things
like eliminate and so on that that come
with the family here
I'm not really eliminates
well I haven't also we haven't
updated eliminates for quite a while
they don't do as many many other things
that that so like it doesn't have uh the
domain argument
it's always assuming everything is
complex
because because we added quantifiers to
these other ones
so that's important to have eliminate
but you should why don't you just make
eliminate just be a
sugar for those other things
uh
I mean we shouldn't let it just die
right
right so it's uh
I wonder whether we can we can just do
the quantity so what would happen over
the reels you you would get a formula
back because right now it
well I mean it should it should do what
it does now but if you want to
re-implement it by just having a trivial
wrapper around something that's in
reduce or solved
then why not
right
eliminates
yeah yeah I I guess we could we could we
could just
read it as a so so right now it it takes
a list of equations and I think it I
wonder whether it returns I'm not quite
sure whether it returns a list of
equations or does the return a Boolean
combination of equations because it
would have to return Boolean
combinations for
for the real case of equations
inequalities yeah right it couldn't work
with the least
fine take a look at it
what about factoring
thirteen three is already done
yeah yeah that was there already
okay
what about the the horror story of
polynomial mod
because polynomial mod is an El Cheapo
version of polynomials of a finite
Fields right
it also take modulus so it takes modular
polynomial
so it it's sort of the the functionality
was extended in a different direction
the modulus could be a polynomial
yourself yes yes
if I put a polynomial over a finite
field
into polynomial mod will it do the right
thing
ah okay so first first question is is
there a right thing uh well yes it's a
look I I know perfectly well okay
in a Time long ago far far away
I was interested in polynomials of the
form on that we can try it here
one plus X okay so I want this over gf2
and what do I do so so okay let me take
this as an example I want to take that
polynomial
over
uh gf2
so I think I would do that normally with
polynomial mod
that thing
what do I say I say modulus ro2 or
something
just two here I think it's just two yeah
okay all right so now my alternative
strategy would be to take one plus X
how do I turn that into a polynomial of
a gf2
um if you tell me I've got to do the
individual coefficients I'm not going to
be a happy person
well unfortunately uh
or or use a function that takes if
foreign
over extension goes to the field
okay
all right so bottom line is we're going
to need this and it's like the from
finite field in you know
this isn't really that name from finite
field index isn't really right because
we want to be able to take one plus X
and turn it into a polynomial over that
field
right yeah
so what's the right function to do that
I mean maybe it's too finite Fields a
form Financial I mean that looks
generally
right and it's sort of independent from
the other functionality so it wouldn't
treat
numbers as indices but rather as as
numbers embedded in the field
right so
so what does that mean for a Prime power
field
that means I don't know what that means
in other words if I have a number
27 in the field uh GF 23 squared what
happens to 27 well it becomes four
I see
I see okay
all right so then this would be
uh
okay so for right now how would I do
this
I'd say finite field two that's gf2
right right sub one
and then I say that thing
plus x to the power of 12 and expand
now I'd say plus this times
yeah and I'd say that thing there
mm-hmm
to the 12 and I'd say expand
and I should get that now if I say
coefficient list here
I think I'm going to get something
horrifying
it's a little funky that I get plain
zeros isn't it
yeah yeah
probably yeah the coefficient lists just
just does the structural thing right so
that's probably wrong
um
should I put this
you probably have characters in Ultra by
somewhere
okay
so some stuff with coefficient and
coefficient list needs to be figured out
probably coefficient is going to do the
wrong thing we'll put another refined
field now if I were to take this thing
here
percent 13 and add
x to the fifth to it
what's that creature
all right so if you try to compute it it
will be embedded in the field but not
not by by just the plus will not do it
so if I were to factor this
what would happen if I had a sum here
that had different fields the different
pieces
ah it would
it will not com complain automatically
but if you if you do some some factoring
that we'll try to do out arithmetic
with those things it will complain
doesn't complain in a civilized way
hopefully
so it will it will complain about every
arithmetic so it will complain about
every arithmetic operations that you do
okay all right so I want to know how to
do this mod
x to the seventh minus one
this thing here
this finite field thing here mod x to
the seventh minus one how would I do
that
do I do a polynomial mod around this
yeah because it will not work over
Finance Fields so well let's see what
will it will do but I
well so I'm just telling you this things
like this should work oh it actually did
work what did you do
well
okay so let me let me do the following
I'm going to do this with a t there
I'm going to do coefficient list
comma X and then I'm going to need the
operation that you didn't give me yet
um
why was that so unbelievably slow okay
so now the operation you didn't give me
is the one that goes which is going to
be incredibly messy here because of all
those zeros
what would I do if I just weren't going
to accurate it accurate this I would
just say slash dot what would I do to
hackerate it
here
fires feel the element goes to it to its
index
whatsoever I underscore if I choose the
element it goes to
elements
goes to a of index
that's very questionable
indeed well what what is questionable
the fact that those are on equal length
ah
this is a cellular automatic an additive
cellular automaton the cyclic boundary
conditions what it's worth
very close to a shift register sequence
that reminds me that this puppy
should support finite field objects
I don't know exactly how well this one
the feedback polynomial poly that should
be allowed to be a finite field
polynomial
that makes sense
Yes No Maybe
Adam I have no idea was it just okay go
look it up it's a it's a very it's one
of the very popular uses of finite
fields
okay and right now this doesn't support
Planet fields and it should
uh
it's I mean in the end I bet you're
gonna need a spouse represent a
representation of something like this
that doesn't wrap finite field relevance
around every single element
but maybe that's for the future don't we
have something like that maybe it's
still interesting we do have something
like that in an internal context that
represents a matrix although it doesn't
have a nice display important to it
it's kind of like the structured array
story yes
okay
that's cool
by the way for your examples you really
should use a smaller field than 23 to
the four because you really should let
people see that these numbers aren't
you know are reduced numbers if you get
what I'm saying
it's completely unobvious to me I mean I
have to think for a minute to realize 23
to the 4 is much bigger than any of
these numbers
but it's not self-evidently obvious
okay
um
okay what else should we see with finite
filter I feel like there needs to be a
little bit more
you know Discovery and exploration
uh
for
you know of what other parts of the
system can make use of finite field
stuff
I I don't know what the right way to do
that is
yeah our application they're looking for
those as well because
now that this available to us we'll be
looking for those as well
no I don't want to know what does work
with finite Fields thank you very much
I want to know what should work with
finite fields
I don't know whether it's even true
is GF a real function
multiplicative order that's an
interesting one does that work with
finite Fields yes
it works with your finite field these
these things here yes
okay does this make any sense
nope nope that's just nonsense
there's a front-end crash bug in today's
build just be careful when you maybe
save your notebook good
that's behind there please
if you do a single tick it crashes I
think in today's films so be careful so
what should I do for my next sale here
if I do a single tick it's going to
crash is that right
okay
uh you were right
so much for that
well anyway I I meant you could try
asking it for it to guess which
functions it's seen related to finite
Fields that's what I'm really asking for
and I think it has a chance of answering
that
makes sense
I just started anyway
why not ask it see if it has anything
sensible to say
come on
great
yeah well thank you thank you AI
stoot that was not that version
what the hell happened there
it's also today's version 14 right well
I don't know what that was I thought it
well who knows
okay
let's have a quick look through this
we're kind of out of time though
um
this all requires some discussion in my
view sure
and for example what's the the
difference between you know a hermitian
matrix or a symmetric Matrix and a
symmetrized array of rank two and that
symmetry
yeah I mean this is blowing up all that
canonicalization
because this is not equally is it
equally equal the original Matrix or not
it's it's definitely equal equal it's
not same Q
yeah is it definitely equal equal
yeah it should be if I were to take this
and I would say normal of that
okay and now I would say this
equal equal
okay
right just like sparse arrays are equal
to lists of this you know lists of the
same
contents
I'm far from thrilled with the look of
this box here
does that do these things mean something
yes that that's uh that that's a right
that's it well with hermitian matrix
it's a bit funny because uh because
Matrix plot is a bit funny brights but
right that's Matrix that's Matrix plot
of the data which uh basically means
it's looking at the real part I believe
is what Matrix plus by default Matrix
plus and complex matrices
um complex plot 3D has a color scheme
yeah we haven't update Matrix
um
Matrix plot
we probably should yeah hopefully we
don't need a complex Matrix plot
right hopefully we just need to make the
default to complex numbers be the right
thing in which case this would inherit
it right right yes it's so certainly
calling Matrix plot with appropriate
options
yeah I think it needs other updates too
unfortunately
those can't really be easily tweaked
without kind of re-implementing them so
it's a little it's not a super cheap job
really it's not just a color scheme it's
it's all in C code it's 2 000 lines in a
file
but but it has but it has some kind of
um
I'm just saying that yeah okay you know
I think it should get updated I think
this it's not based on the you know the
visualization team has a lot of
capabilities that we do and put in this
was not written by a visualization team
okay so yeah
it has its you know it does what it does
or maybe it's not bad right
yeah okay
totally 30 years old
no but it has some years
Maybe
25. yeah
well I mean I think what came out with
five
one maybe five oh around there I don't
know exactly so so Matrix Matrix plot
was new in six so 2007. okay we have
prototypes in five but probably released
that's really quite modern less than 20
years old
yes we've got we've got younger people
working at the company right a rape
array plot was introduced in five one
Matrix plot which is 2004. uh Matrix
plot came in six in 2007.
all right plot was oh we were using
raster before that for those things that
was horrifying yeah
okay I mean Matrix spot has some good
features but we know a lot more that
would be useful so fair enough
look this target structure business
it gives user control to it
um
and was suggested by you
right but I mean obviously you can put a
wrapper around that
um
uh
yeah but yeah this well for for for for
things that do as right for single
Matrix constructures sure you can do
that if it's a a decomposition which may
have multiple matrices then you know
it's not so obvious yeah right and there
are examples of laid on exactly but I
think decompositions you know were long
pre-association
so to speak and they would have been
nicer you know and not as totally
incomprehensible
with this right yeah agreed I mean
that's so so what is done
is that for you as an advanced user of
course you know it's an upper triangular
Matrix and when you
use that later on to solve you know so
Lu for instance it gives you a lower and
an upper triangle I know that's
absolutely horrifying right but you have
to know that as a user so you later on
you call a lower triangular solver an
upper triangular solver exactly so it
should just take it as a it should be it
should return something which has
structured matrices in there so that you
can't do the wrong thing exactly
just so
I have a feeling we're going to need a
newly named LED composition because I
think I think that is not a good you we
can't really do
the um incompatible change of changing
the return value yes and that's not part
of the reason because we had to do some
discussion on what it should be Etc like
should be called Alum matrices there and
what exactly but it would definitely be
a new name for sure yes pretty much more
useful than what we have right now for
sure I agree
okay
well let me just just take quick looks
okay so that's the end versions of the
things we saw in the last version yes
exactly
with some updates to the earlier
functions to make sure that they are
we've addressed all the issues reported
so far
suggestions
this is to address the workflow
that happens as we give solutions that
are infinite sums
inactive infinite sums
yes
I mean this is like a power series it's
not not completely crazy except are we
going to have truncate product as well
well we talked about but I think
truncate we don't have that many
products coming out of that form and
then for this one we got desolved
dissolved value we've got uh asymptotic
got lots right I mean this is basically
the analog of normal of series of
whatever
um no
um Sirius is always finite
so I see what you're saying these ones
are explicitly infinite
so
um
yeah but no but you can I mean the
alternative will be to say just like
truncate sum comma n will be series you
know comma n basically and then normal
of that
like taking taking the thing you've got
and finding an end term approximation to
it
yes but this very this is completely
structural it's not true no I get it I
get it okay well though I don't know
quite what truncate some double you've
got a minus infinity one here yeah so we
then we document that what that means
because you probably want to start close
to zero I mean that's a matter of you
know what you'd like to do but based on
use cases we have so those are the
actual use cases it says if you go to
the reference page it says yeah exactly
but is singly infinite doubly infinite
etc etc okay so here's a piece of trivia
for you all so I happen to be
um was it a month ago or something for
very very random reasons I have to be in
Strasbourg France I'm wandering along
the street
and I look up
and there's a plaque on the house that
says this was the birthplace of Paul
Appel wow
so
and I took a picture of it and that's
that's as far as I went I didn't think
it quite right you know
um
Rose to the level of a tweet or anything
um not quite I squared equals J squared
equals K squared equals i j k no I
haven't been to that bridge I've never
been to Ireland actually my whole life
the um
okay well we've got many things to talk
about next time
um we've got to start here uh and I
think we continue where we left off and
uh
um looks looks great
thank you great see you all soon okay
bye